hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game from yesterday's speed
Chess Championship Match it's Yani
Punisher versus Magnus Carlsen and this
from the bullet section we're gonna
discuss the standings after we check out
the game but this one it's absolutely
incredible again players played an
incredible accuracy uh for for a bullet
game so uh let's uh see what happened
here Nepal had the white pieces and he
opened with Ponte E4 Magnus played
Knight to F6 with Ponte E5 challenging
alecking's defense with the advancement
of the pawn and now usually Knight to D5
is played and there are over 30 000
games from Top tier tournaments where
this position has been reached but
Magnus does not play Knights to D5 which
is uh officially the only playable move
in the position Magnus goes Knight back
to G8 and now look at what happens we
have pawned the D4 by nepo and now it's
basically Magnus like like Magnus is
starting from a starting position where
nipple already has three moves in E4
sorry about the E4 E5 and and pawn to D4
and it is kind of is in the spirit of
the original idea of a Legend's defense
where you want to challenge white spawns
you want to get them all uh for example
D4 e5c for F4 and then undermine those
pawns later on with some moves like um
D6 and attacking the pawns with pieces
but not the G8 that's pushing it a bit
too far if you if you played this uh
like if you were in a chess school and
your your chess teacher saw this he
would probably throw you out of the
class and say you should never practice
chess again but when you are at this
level you can obviously play anything so
now Pawn to D6 now it's time to
challenge nipples Advanced Center and
Knight to F3 we have Pawn to see six
stars and games where Bishop to G4 is
played but C6 is incredibly rare the
only person had to have ever played C6
in this position is Magnus Carlsen
himself but he played it some 10 years
ago in 20 in 2014 uh he played in a
world the blitz Championship I have
against his second Lauren fresenay and
he won that game but in that game alran
played Ponte H3 but here we have Knight
to C3 by nepo and it is now already as
of move 5 that we have a completely new
game so let's see what the idea is here
Bishop to G4 and Bishop to G4 already
comes with a very nasty threat with
Bishop to E2 and now Knight to D7 kind
of forcing nipple to capture on D6 which
is already a small victory for black um
and you always want to force your
opponent to make an unnecessary trade
because if you just Castle here then the
thread is already you just capture and
after Bishop captures you win a pawn
here D captures on E5 that's that's
pretty much it so nepo has the trade he
captures on D6 with e Captain D6 and now
castles with Knight G2 F6 Ponte H3
Magnus trades Bishop for Knight here
captures captures and pawn to D5 and
look at already how magnus's position
comes alive uh from uh what was once in
uh in the defense now he has spawns on
light squares he has very nicely placed
Knights and the bishop will nicely
complemented those pawns and dark
squares as all of the pawns are on light
squares so here rookie one check Bishop
to E7 and Bishop to F4 now we have
Knight to f8 not castling right away
Magnus first wants to re-maneuver the
Knight to E6 so Knight to f8 we have
Queen to D3 and now Knight the E6
attacking the bishop on F4 you have to
move it Bishop to E5 and only now Magnus
castles we have knighted the E2 at the
pawn here
uh isn't uh all that impressive and you
want to either defend it with C3 or you
want to prepare Pawn to C4 so the Knight
really should move and come to G3 later
on you can come to F5 input pressure on
the bishop and on the G7 Pawn don't
Bishop to D6 and now Knight to G3 Magnus
trades on E5 we have Bishop capture
spawn captures and now Knight to D7 just
putting pressure on that pawn uh and the
nipple goes Knight to F5 and it looks
like an amazing square for the Knight
especially with the pawn being an E5 you
can put the Knight on D6 uh the problem
is magnus's that's not really the case
he just plays G6 and now although it
looks like you can play Knight to D6 if
you play these magnets with just capture
and E5 and now your knight uh
uh will be lost and it also cost you a
pawn so after G6 we have Knight to H6
check by nepo King G7 and Knight back to
G4 and again okay the Knight is
excellently placed on G4 so of course
magnets will not allow it to remain
there Pawn to H5 and now nipple has to
make a very unpleasant Choice does he go
Knight to E3 and alumni captures an E5
or does he want to play the passive
Knights the H2 move which could run into
some Queen G5 ideas Knight to F4 and
already white could be in big trouble so
instead nepo goes Knight to E3 it's a
temporary Pawn sacrifice but nipple has
something utter in mind than just
winning back his Pawn Knight captures on
E5 and now you can play Queen C3 Queen
C3 looks like a great move but D4 just
wins the game there's no defense against
this so NEPA finds Knight to F5 check
now he says all right you take my knight
I'm gonna capture your knight on E5 and
I'm gonna mess up your defenses in front
of your king but Magnus uh well he just
laughs in his face and he plays King to
F6 and now once you see this and the
king is actually very safe and F6
defending the Knight
uh you know that things uh have taken a
bit of a wrong turn here and you have no
choice but to continue in the in the
same fashion so as they say you know in
for a penny in for a pound Rook captures
an E5 so inviting the black king further
in King captures on E5 and now look at
this
shouldn't there be something that you
can do to Checkmate that black king
after all the night is preventing King
to D6 uh so if you could uh if you could
somehow do it it'd be great but the
problem is after Queen to C3 check King
captures on F5 and you could even
continue uh G4 check let's say captures
captures uh very nicely controlling all
of these squares but the problem is King
G5 and if King G5 even H4 check you can
even give up the bishop here but uh you
will not be checkmating the black king
there is no mate the G5 square is
guarded and that's pretty much it once
you give one more check the king will
come to H6 and the King escapes so here
after King captures an E5 and nepo goes
Rook D1 with check and okay you
introduce one more attacker into the
attack King back to F6 and now Knights
the D4 the idea is that if Knight
captures on D4 then nepo actually gets
the Checkmate the black king because
after check King G5 are gonna play Queen
to E3 with checking F6 and queen to E5
will be Checkmate but Magnus of course
doesn't allow that he plays a rook to E8
and now not a lot you can do although it
seems still like a very promising
position for nepo he does find the
absolute best Queen to C3 and now uh how
are you defending this position you
can't really move the king if you go at
the D file then you will have some
problems here there is only one move
that solves the position for Magnus and
it is in fact the only winning move so
feel free to pause the video and win the
game for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on finding this
incredible solution and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it is
King to G I'm only kidding it is Queen
to B6 that's the move so if you found
this you are truly an exceptional player
big congratulations uh the point is that
even though nipple has some very nasty
discoveries here towards the black king
there's just uh there just isn't a good
one and to give you an example let's say
Knight captures an E6 check looks
incredible you give a check the Knight
here is defended you're preventing the
king from going to G7 the king cannot
even come to E7 because then you have
further discoveries with the Knight but
there's always the problem of D4 and
this D4 move uh is you know basically
black stronghold and it is the movement
preventing white from achieving any sort
of
um uh attack that can be fully realized
and now after night characters on D4 for
example you will simply trade Rook
captures anyone check Wing characters
and queen captures on D4 you will be up
the exchange and of course have a
completely winning position there's no
way to continue even you know asking
questions here so after Queen to be six
nipple tried Rook captures an E6 check
which means he gives up the second
exchange F captures an E6 and now he
played Queen to E3 again there are no
good discoveries if you play Knight
captures on C6 with check again D4 and
okay now you can capture back Knight
captures on D4 now Rook ACA to attack
the queen and once the queen moves uh
literally any move is fine but strong as
this Pawn to E5 you chase away the
Knight once the Knight moves you chase
away the bishop wants the bishop moves
you can even play Pawn to E3 and it's uh
resigns time so after F characters and
E6 Queen the E3 was played trying to
stir some trouble here maybe with Queen
to F4 but Magnus of course solves that
he plays Pawn to E5 and he was in this
position on move 28 that Yani publisher
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here there are no useful
checks uh once you move the knight uh
magnets will simply trade here captures
captures upon the E4 you have two Rooks
against bishop and Knight of course this
is completely winning you can play this
however you want to of course nepo is
not interested in that so after E5 he
resigned and a very very nice victory
for Magnus Carlsen in the bullet section
of the speed Chess Championship
quarterfinals and for those of you who
are interested in how sorry about that
have to fix this a little bit how the
entire match went uh well there you have
it um
uh this is uh how the match went uh so
the quarterfinal match between Magnus
Carlsen and Yani ponichi so in the five
plus one section magnets was slightly
better five and a half to three and a
half but then in the three plus one
section Magnus was even better with six
to three and then in the bullet section
Magnus was much much better as he uh
practically destroyed Yan uh with a
score of nine to three uh leading it to
a total score of 20 and a half to nine
and a half so uh more than more than
double the points which is absolutely
incredible as you all know Yan was a
former World Chase Championship
Challenger not once but twice but this
is not classical chess uh this is Blitz
and bullet and you know it's it's a much
much different world here uh so yeah
that's the game really hope you guys
enjoyed it uh again it's always uh it's
always unbelievable that players can
play Such moves uh you know in in bullet
format uh so I mean we can just marvel
at that but what are you gonna do that's
why uh they are they are uh chess
Legends and why we enjoy watching their
games so much so once again
congratulations to everyone who found
that Queen this B6 move it's not an easy
move to spot especially leaving your
king here exposed like this but it is
what you have to find and Magnus found
that uh well very very quickly pretty
much instantly so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it if you haven't
seen my previous video do check it out
will be the link in the description
below you have a chance to face alireza
if you do really well so more info will
be uh in in my previous video do check
it out and maybe you guys will have a
chance to play against alireza and maybe
even defeat him and maybe even have your
game featured on this channel even if
you lose if you lose very nicely we'll
see how it goes so yeah once again hope
you enjoy it uh I would uh like to wish
a very happy birthday to Matt mate and I
would like to thank Lucas Robinson
Florian Fogel uh Carmen polifrono and
Kim dolman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here and thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you want
suggestions and everything that happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day